costume changes bedazzling Galore the
number 13 friendship bracelets what
doesn't the era's tour have it's
projected to be the first tour to ever
gross more than one billion dollars and
the average resale price for a ticket
has been estimated at 1607 bucks to put
that in context the average resale price
for tickets for her reputation tour was
191 bucks so yeah era's ticks cost a lot
more of course Taylor and her team are
apparently spending about 750 thousand
dollars a day to put on these incredible
shows and while the official movie about
the tour doesn't come out until October
we decided to do a little behind the
scenes peaking of our own let's break
down a little of the lengths Taylor and
crew went to in order to put together
this once in a lifetime spectacle fans
of Taylor are well aware of her classic
bedazzled guitar that she played on The
Fearless tour the silver sparkly ax has
become one of the many iconic look that
Taylor has made famous over the years so
when it came to the era's tour it seemed
like a no-brainer to have a bedazzled
guitar as part of the show but Taylor
went a pretty unusual route when it came
to having a new one made for the tour
her parents made it for her she shared a
photo on her IG story before the tour
started and it featured a couple of
hands placing silver rhinestones onto a
guitar complete with the lucky number 13
on it Taylor's tongue-in-cheek post said
quote was my era's tour crystallized
Fearless guitar made by a Artisans and
finely trained Craftsman b a
professional musical instrument
manufacturer C my parents with super
glue and a free afternoon and though she
joked that it was not C it clearly was
nice to see that prepping for the era
tour was a family thing speaking of
helping out family Taylor wanted to make
sure that her dad felt like a true VIP
on the tour and while I'm pretty sure he
was going to have an all-access pass to
any show he wanted Taylor decided to go
the extra mile she created a hand-drawn
backstage pass just for her dad the pass
which clearly was made to look like it
was drawn by an adoring daughter reads
Doh dad of headliner I don't know if
Taylor's dad actually rocked it during
the shows or if he did the classic move
of putting an up on their home fridge
either way it was super adorable
Taylor's kindness extended Beyond her
family members she's well aware of the
kind of boost that an opening slot in
her tour can have for an artist so she
hand-picked a handful of amazing artists
to join her on the tour their reactions
ranged from Pure Elation to feeling like
they were victims of a cruel joke Owen
said that the call to join the tour
quote meant that Taylor really believed
in me and that my life was going to be
forever changed and Bieber doobie
remembered it as a serious Pinch Me
moment meanwhile Gracie Abrams admitted
that she'd been dreaming about playing
shows with Taylor before she'd even had
dreams about playing her own shows and
when she got the offer to open on the
eras tour she totally thought she was
being pranked said Gracie I was like
this can't be right Gail talked about
how she'd been a part of a show in
Nashville where she performed in front
of an audience that included Taylor and
afterwards Taylor sought her out
backstage they chatted for a bit and
then Taylor surprised her by hinting of
more things to come she was just like
you did a great perform comments I'm
gonna call you Taylor has a knack for
making stylish and fun announcements and
that also included the announcement of
the tour in the first place Taylor put
the word out on Instagram posting on
March 16 2023 she donned several outfits
across a bunch of photos showing her in
rehearsals getting ready for the tour
her caption was simple in my era's era
she also added to the fervor by
releasing four new tracks at the time
eyes open Taylor's version safe and
sound Taylor's version if this was a
movie Taylor's version and all of the
girls You Loved Before when it came to
the actual shows Taylor held nothing
back as she prepared that started by
bringing in an All-Star group of dancers
and choreographers a lot of these folks
have danced with Taylor before so it was
a natural fit at the top of the dance
chain was legendary choreographer Mandy
Moore Moore has done choreography for
projects ranging from the hit movie La
La Land to shows like So You Think You
Can Dance and Dancing with the Stars she
was joined by Jeremy Hudson and Amanda
Balon both of whom have done choreo for
Lady Gaga among others and the dancers
are a slew of uber talented people who
have danced with the top acts in the
world though clearly if you get the call
to dance on the eras tour you drop
everything Taylor also brought in her
go-to band The Agency for the tour
they've been with her for years so there
was a lot less time up front for hiccups
and issues Taylor is very
detail-oriented when it comes to
costumes and the era's tour was perhaps
the Pinnacle of that in each show she
goes through 16 outfit changes with a
resulting 17 fully distinct outfits
they're meant to represent the last 17
years of her incredible career and
obviously to bring added Flair to the
production and the outfits and changes
were all planned out to a t because
there's little time for lengthy changes
during the show of course Taylor's fans
have been adding some costume Flair of
their own in the form of friendship
bracelets making wearing and trading
these Little Gems has become a major
part of The Fan Experience on the tour
the bracelets usually reference song
lyrics album eras or even inside jokes
from within the Swifty world and if you
missed the eras tour you're not
completely out of luck you'll have a
chance to see a behind the scenes and
immersive look at the tour with the
release of a full-length movie about it
it'll be called Taylor Swift the era's
tour and it'll arrive in theaters
October 13th of this year Taylor posted
on Instagram saying quote the aristor
has been the most meaningful electric
experience of my life so far and I'm
Overjoyed to tell you that it'll be
coming to the big screen soon she added
era's attire friendship bracelets
singing and dancing and courage if you
didn't catch Taylor's show during the
American portion of the 2023 tour you're
still in luck she's about to start up
again in various spots around the globe
so as long as you don't mind a nice long
flight you can catch her in countries
like France Ireland Singapore and more
or if you're really patient you can wait
until late 2024 when Swift brings it
back to the US and I'm sure tickets for
those will be you know totally easy to
get have any thoughts about Taylor's
preparation for the arrows tour pop them
in the comment section below